Raphaël Arca bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes communicants docteur en
philosophie du langage expert associé à
la Fondation Jean Jaurès auteur de la
marque Macron alors pour tout vous dire
on était censé commenter la campagne
présidentielle comme c'est le cas chaque
mardi ici l'actualité en a décidé
autrement il y a évidemment ses annonces
du président russe et cette menace de
guerre qui pèse à l'est de l'Europe et
qui est sans doute en train de se
concrétiser il y avait quelques instants
un forum ministériel pour la coopération
dans l'Indo Pacifique organisé à Paris
Jean-Yves Le Drian je te donne la
diplomatie française s'exprimer aux
côtés de l'Européen Joseph Borel tous
deux ont été interrogés par la presse
tous deux on refusé de de s'exprimer sur
ce qui est en train de se passer à l'est
à l'est de l'Ukraine et aussi assez
étonnant aussi étonnant que cela soit
Emmanuel Macron lui aussi est assez
discret depuis ce matin que peut-il se
passer dans les couloirs de la
diplomatie française aujourd'hui on sent
bien l'embarras et la difficulté à
s'exprimer à commenter aussi ce qui est
en train de se jouer là
je le précise d'entrer je ne suis pas du
tout un spécialiste des relations
internationales moi j'essaie de te
regarder la situation de mon de ma
casquette à moi qui me touche celle d'un
communicant effectivement on est en
train d'assister à quelque chose qui est
assez inédit c'est-à-dire qu'on va
assister probablement en en dans une
campagne présidentielle en plein dans le
plus grave conflit armé en Europe depuis
au moins 1945 c'était les mots de
Jean-Louis bourge hier sur France Inter
on est en train on est encore tous dans
l'incertitude de savoir comment est-ce
que se confirmer va avoir une
répercussion sur la campagne en tant que
président sortant pas encore candidat il
est effectivement dans une sorte de
difficulté c'est-à-dire qu'à la fois il
est obligé de jouer le rôle de président
et dans un moment grave historique en
train de se dérouler et en même temps on
le voit bien
c'est une difficulté pour lui de trouver
les bonnes façons d'éventuellement de se
déclarer candidat alors il est coincé
au départ
au Kremlin puisse éventuellement
accoucher d'une d'une réussite
diplomatique on voit bien
qu'effectivement ce conflit armé rend
les choses plus difficiles pour lui ce
qui m'interroge ce qui m'interpelle
aussi et peut-être plus en lien avec le
livre que je publie cette semaine sur
sur l'extrême droite c'est
qu'effectivement cette question vient
percuter cette campagne y compris dans
le discours d'Éric Zemmour et Marine Le
Pen qui on le sait était
traditionnellement plutôt considéré
comme non pas peut-être des alliés mais
disons étant en ayant un discours plus
bienveillant vis-à-vis de venir pour te
donc toutes ces choses-là sont en train
de re balayer de rabattre les cartes on
est on est bien coincé pour savoir
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui va se passer
on a complètement occulté la politique
française depuis ce matin qui a annoncé
suspendre sa campagne en pleine course
au parrainage il en faut 500 on en est
encore très loin de ce côté-là pour en
revenir au chef de l'État on l'a vu
particulièrement actif donner sa
personne et qu'on pré physiquement aller
à Moscou aller à Kiev passant des coups
de téléphone encore ce weekend et
justement complètement coincé
aujourd'hui on n'imagine pas le chef de
l'État français se déclarer candidat à
la veille peut-être d'une guerre d'une
guerre avec avec les Russes
lui qui aime toujours se réclamer être
le maître des horloges effectivement là
il est dépendant de situation
internationale il ne peut pas faire
autrement donc effectivement et je
constate même que certains y compris
dans le bloc frontiste appelle plutôt
être fédéré autour de la voie du
président de la République en disant
qu'effectivement j'ai vu un réaction
Robert Ménard ce matin qui disait qu'il
fallait on n'étant patriotique c'était
aussi une façon de de d'avoir de parler
d'une même voix celle de la France donc
on voit bien que Macron fait son job
simplement il a été manipuler
instrumentalisé par Vladimir Poutine ça
c'est Patrick années à présent du groupe
socialiste au Sénat qui a réagi
puisqu'on évoque les rations politiques
c'est vrai qu'il y en a un certain
nombre tous font autour du chef de
l'État même s'il y a quand même des
critiques des mini il a attendu un peu
trop longtemps
présidentielle donc c'est aussi le choix
de faire le jeu de la politique d'aller
taper un peu ce président s'entend mais
si on allait rechercher ses lignes de
faille je crois qu'effectivement sa
ligne de Crète était extrêmement mince
je pense que c'était courageux de sa
part d'aller au Kremlin parce qu'il
avait en réalité beaucoup pas perdre et
très peu à gagner donc je pense qu'on
peut saluer cette initiative là on voit
qu'il est encore à la manœuvre
aujourd'hui
les espoirs les sorties de crise
diplomatique enfin les possibilités de
résoudre cette crise par les voies
diplomatiques sont pas encore épuisées
racontant du côté de l'Élysée je crois
qu'il va jusqu'au bout tenter de
d'éviter le confirmer et il est appelé
par l'écologiste Yannick Jadot
aujourd'hui à recevoir l'intégralité des
candidats justement à la présidentielle
pour évoquer cette cette crise
ukrainienne alors on a aussi du mal à
imaginer où est-ce qu'il va se
positionner dans un tel rendez-vous vous
qui avez écrit la la marque Macron
est-ce que finalement il est pas aussi
dans ce qu'il préfère le chef de l'État
il est dans l'improvisation en sa
compagne elle va être extrêmement
réduite quelques semaines ça c'est assez
inédit aussi même si les présidents
sortants ont l'habitude de se déclarer
au dernier moment là le timing il est
extrêmement serré il y a deux scénarios
en réalité le premier scénario lequel
effectivement se conflit le reposition
président vertical Jupiter rien cette
position qu'il affectionne
particulièrement ou effectivement il
pourrait faire une campagne extrêmement
courte et rester à ce niveau très élevé
duquel il est dans les sondages existe
un autre scénario peut-être beaucoup
plus dangereux pour lui oui
effectivement on a l'habitude de dire
que les conflits nationaux ont peu
d'impact sur l'opinion publique
française là tout va se jouer dans les
prochaines heures et dans les prochains
jours c'est-à-dire la perception de
cette réaction de l'avenir Poutine sur
la sur l'opinion publique française
est-ce que ce sera perçu comme étant une
humiliation diplomatique ou un coup de
force de Vladimir Poutine versus la
France qui serait une fois encore
eu égard au précédent
difficultés cependant
marin australien est-ce que c'est un
énième épisode de l'affaiblissement la
voix de la France où est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui qui tendrait à la
verticaliser davantage